freezing antifreeze what oh yeah there's
a nice healthy chunk of antifreeze right
there
what no it's not possible so how does he
freeze antifreeze antifreeze is the
common name for ethylene glycol which is
used to stop car radiators freezing this
is because it's got an incredibly low
freezing point of minus 36 degrees
Fahrenheit on minus thirty seven point
seven degrees Celsius this means that
even though it's called antifreeze you
can still freeze it if you gets it cold
enough to freeze the antifreeze grant
uses liquid nitrogen
now nitrogen has a boiling point of
minus 321 degrees Fahrenheit that's
minus 196 degrees Celsius that makes it
a lot lot a lot colder than the freezing
point of the antifreeze the antifreeze
and the nitrogen want to read too it's
called thermal equilibrium when he puts
the relatively warmer room-temperature
antifreeze in to the much colder liquid
nitrogen they both want to reach the
same temperature the liquid nitrogen
will do this by heating up which is why
we see it boiling
while the antifreeze is going to lose
some of that heat and this is why it
freezes because the liquid nitrogen is
so cold it takes virtually no time for
the heat to leave the antifreeze
bringing it below its freezing
temperature turning it into a solid oh
yeah there's a nice healthy chunk of
antifreeze right there antifreeze is
incredibly poisonous and liquid nitrogen
is dangerously cold so definitely do not
try this at home